chez les gens cassent les ciseaux donc
il ya là il ya des risques à lui qu'ils
sont là on va se rappeler dans une
minute d'accord moi je vais prendre
l'ascenseur
[Rires]
[Musique]
arthur est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait du bien m'amuser ça tout va bien
ça va je suis très content d'être là
mais moi aussi le premier en bas aura le
droit de prendre la carte qui est ici et
de la mettre dans la lah la balle dans
le visage si les équipes gentiment eu
l'élégance de me changer tee shirt
wen au mieux un t-shirt pour ses berges
peut pas même pas bougé débat ça te va
très bien bien ça veut rien savoir udine
nord ça te boudine pas bien avec moi
remonte au 5e set très serré on est
ailleurs à faire le chip ou bi pour
savoir qui prend l'ascenseur et qui
prend les escape d'accord attention
syrie oui chiffonniers j'ai pas joué
depuis 30 ans alors pierre feuille
ciseaux car l'accord attention le puits
est éliminatoire tu d'accord si tu fais
le puits on l'appellera tf1 tu seras
même viré le tfc quoi le puits le plus
et ça d'accord ok attention chez il faut
mais je casse les ciseaux donc il ya là
il y avait celui qui sont là on va se
rappeler dans une minute d'accord moi je
vais prendre l'ascenseur c'est parti au
niveau sportif
[Applaudissements]
je suis bien là
moore cyril
c'est le croquer
[Applaudissements]
à la santé de tpm p
cobra d'un côté vendeur je vous
racontais je ralentis ce qui s'est passé
les femmes
vivis cac est à peine croyable attendait
alors que tu voudras sa soeur j'ai
appuyé sur des étages avant ya des mecs
et julia des maquettes aux deux ans a
répondu je crois que jamais de leur vie
se sont fait insulter comme ça les gens
mon ordi celle des morts comme ça c'est
pas fait pour être appelé bondoukou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]